it looks like heavy weather's on the way
a faster spreading variant of covid at
large in the uk with just a few weeks of
christmas
will omicron be worse than what's come
before that depends on tests being done
in labs like this one i think it'll have
a bit of both it'll have some immune
evasion and and some enhanced
infectivity that give it an overall edge
but as i'm saying you know we're hoping
that that does not translate to more
severe disease
understanding what's giving omicron it's
edge will be key to informing how we
respond booster jabs could be all we
need to keep people out of hospital but
if it spreads as fast as early data
suggests should we be acting faster
would you agree with far more immunized
than in previous waves it's a tough call
what we can absolutely say with with
near certainty now is that that omicron
is is more transmissible and is going to
become the dominant virus in the uk we
know the impact that another lost
christmas would have on people and and
and so it's a really difficult policy
decision from a scientific perspective
i would
certainly start to like to see things
like a walk from home edict for the next
few weeks or months
um
and and maybe a reintroduction of some
social distancing and for example
workplaces and so on
for the time being all eyes will be on
the data from labs like this one in
cambridge these machines at the sanger
institute are doing about 90 of all our
surveillance for covid variants it takes
about four days from a positive sample
coming in to its entire genome being
unraveled and the results uploaded at
the moment they're seeing just a
fraction of a percentage of cases
belonging to the omicron variant but the
way things are going
it could quite soon be the only new
variant they see
the uk's network of gene sequencing labs
are scrutinizing 60 000 covered cases a
week more than nearly anyone else in the
world it's an advantage but a limited
one
what was becoming abundantly clear now
is that this is a global problem you
know we can't leave
vaccination in one country neglected we
can't leave genomic surveillance in one
country neglected i think it just really
reinforces the fact that we've got to be
more equitable with resources both
scientifically for surveillance but also
for the access to the vaccines
the pandemic has taught us all how to
keep our distance to slow covered spread
the lesson we're still learning is how
to work together to stop it once and for
all tom clark sky news cambridge